la campagne de recrutement 2018 du
printemps de bourges est bel et bien
parti le festival c'est maintenant 300
emplois en cdd leurs commandes puisque
puisque je leur fais chaque année donc
voilà et puis effectivement je le
recommande à ceux qui ont envie d'avoir
une petite expérience là j'ai une amie
qui a pas eu d'expérience encore sur le
milieu du travail donc je lui ai proposé
à les intéresser pour pour faire soit
jean d'orientation ou agent d'entretien
première étape une pré inscription sur
internet pour une prise de rendez vous
avec des conseillers pôle emploi
facilitant le positionnement des
candidats
l'objectif c'est de remplir sa fiche de
candidature d'amener son cv et
d'effectuer un petit test de logique
suite à cela toutes les candidatures
sont remontés intégralement printemps de
bourges qui effectuera et ses équipes à
partir du mois de mars des postes
d'agents d'orientation et des agents
d'entretien pour garantir le bon
déroulement de la prochaine édition du
festival alors vous avez plus de 18 ans
vous êtes en mesure de travailler de
jour comme de nuit
rejoignez l'équipe du printemps de
bourges postuler jusqu'au 9 mars sur je
participe tirer événement point pole
emploi.fr l'édition 2018 de festival
berruyer commencera le 24 avril et se
terminera le 29 avril